dienat bonjour à tous les sénateurs
reprennent ce matin l'examen du projet
de loi sur les métropoles avec bien sûr
l'épineuse question du Grand Paris hier
soir suite à deux amendements centristes
et UMP les sénateurs en séance ont
rejeté la création du haut cons cons des
territoires ce matin ils reprennent
l'examen du texte à l'article 4 sur les
conférences territoriales et sachez bien
sûr que l'article 12 qui reprend toutes
les dispositions sur l'épineuse question
du Grand Paris sera examiné cet
après-midi à partir de 16h15 très bonne
séance à
tous l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de
la discussion en 2è lecture du projet de
loi modifié par l'Assemblée nationale de
modernisation de l'action publique
territoriale et d'affirmation des
métropoles dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'amendement numéro
269 au sein de l'article
4 j'ai deux amendements identiques
faisant l'objet d'une discussion
commune monsieur Carles monsieur yes non
il n'est pas
défendu l'amendement
584 monsieur
Germain non plus il
tombe l'amendement 364 tif monsieur
mard la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cet amendement a
pour but d'insérer un alinéa après
l'alinéa 4 et d'indiquer que la
conférence peut saisir pour avis la
commission consultative d'évaluation des
normes de toutes normes réglementaires
en vigueur applicable aux collectivités
territoriales leur groupement et à leurs
établissements euh
publics puisque nous nous nous
constatons que la lutte pour la
simplification des normes prend un tour
complexe pour ne pas dire assez
paradoxal la réforme de la commission
consultative d'évaluation des normes est
portée aujourd'hui par au moins trois
textes différents qui en sont à des
stades de navette divers il y a une
proposition de loi portant création
d'une autre autorité chargée de la
régulation des normes un projet de loi
sur
l'égalité des territoires don qui dont
nous sommes saisis et maintenant le
présent projet de de
loi donc au niveau de l'inflation
normative qui gangrainene depuis
longtemps l'action publique locale nous
considérons que il faut intervenir dans
le sens qui est proposé par cet
amendement merci Monsieur mard je vais
donc demander l'avis de la commission
sur l'article sur l'amendement 364
rectifié monsieur le
rapporteur lundi
après-midi le Sénat examine la
proposition de loi de Madame gourau de
Monsieur suur instituant le Conseil
national d'évaluation des normes qui
succède à l'actuelle
CCEN ce texte prévoit que les
collectivités territoriales pourront
saisir le Conseil national
euh d'évaluation des normes de toutes
normees
réglementair en vigueur applicable au
collectivité selon des modalités fixées
par décret j'observe que d'ailleurs
c'est à l'unanimité que cette
disposition a été approuvé hier à la
commission des lois connaissant votre
élégance démocratique légende
peut-être que cet argument pourrait
justifier le retrait
quoi Monsieur le Rapporteur l'avis du
Gouvernement madame la
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur sénateur je ne serurais pas
mieux dire que ce que vient de de
développer le rapporteur et
effectivement donc lundi après-midi nous
serons là sur un texte qui répond je
crois très dans sa globalité aux
observations qui sont les vôtres les
collectivités orial seront donc amenés à
saisir autant que de besoin et chaque
fois qu'elles sentiront qu'il y a des
normes qui pèsent sur les collectivités
à les saisir pour en simplifier le droit
donc je crois que effectivement ce
serait un retrait qui paraîtrait être
une bonne manière merci madame la
ministre monsieur le Président mesard
vous êtes sollicité pour un retrait que
décidez-vous bien madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur je ne peux en effet que
partager le souci du rapporteur que
l'élégance et la transparence deviennent
des vertus communes dans cet
hémicycle je j'entends que l'amendement
est retiré monsieur mzard il est retiré
merci l'amendement 501 rectifié est
présenté par Madame
nipietz merci merci madame la
Présidente nous avons entendu hier que
certains étaient choqués que ce soit le
président du conseil régional qui
préside de la conférence d'action
territoriale publique euh effectivement
on aurait pu euh le les les lire au sein
de la Conférence mais personnellement ce
n'est pas là où pour moi il y a un
problème le président du conseil
régional parce que justement il
est sa son son sa sphère de de
compétence recouvre l'ensemble du
territoire régional me paraissait être
quelqu'un à même de présider l'ensemble
de
des problèmes enfin la conférence
d'action publique
territoriale mais en revanche ce qui me
choque profondément comme je l'ai dit
dans ma dans ma discussion générale hier
c'est que nous créons des cumuls mandat
fonction en permanence et que nous
proposons encore une fois que le
président du conseil régional soit aussi
président du de cette conférence
d'action territoriale d'où mon idée que
pour un petit peu enlever couper le lien
au sein de la Conférence de l'action
territoriale publique entre la région et
son brésident on face du président
lorsqu'il est président du conseil
régional lorsqu'il est président de
l'action la conférence de l'action
territoriale publique réellement le
président de cette action neutre ce par
rapport à tout le reste et pour cela et
bien il y aurait quatre représentants
désignés de manière paritaire de la
région qui siégeraiit à la conférence
qui permettrait que le président de la
région se consacre effectivement dans
ces cas-là à ses fonctions de président
de la Conférence de l'action
territoriale publique et soit en quelque
sorte neutre puisque la défense s'il y a
défense de la des intérêt de la région
serait dévolu à ces quatre représentants
merci chers collègues je vais demander
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur on va pas si vous voulez bien
mes chers collègues en vous remerciant
pour votre présence ce matin on va
peut-être pas ressusciter les débats
d'hier hein donc je rappelle la CTAP
dans la version allégée que nous avons
voulu se veut une conférence des
exécutifs et non une instance de
représentation de chaque niveau de
collectivité dès lors la commission des
lois a émis un avis défavorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de de la
ministre même avis madame la Présidente
merci bien je vais donc mettre au voit
l'amendement 501 rectifié qui a reçu
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
merci
contre merci abstention l'amendement
n'est pas adopté le 360 rectifié
monsieur le Président mesard vous le
présentez merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers
collègues par cet amendement puisque
hier le Sénat a maintenu les conférences
territoriales de l'action publique
contre notre vote j'en redirai un mot
tout à l'heure autant qu'elle le soit
dans des conditions j'allais dire les
moins pires
possibles le Sénat en première lecture
avait longuement débattu de la
composition de ces conférences
territoriales en particulier de leur
représentativité au regard des petites
collectivités qui bien évidemment sont
inquiète de la composition de ces
conférences et notre groupe avait
proposer plusieurs amendements visant à
abaisser substantiellement le seuil
initial de 50000 habitants retenus pour
désigner les maires et présidents de
communautés de commune représentant les
élus de leur
département il y avait eu une solution
de compromis devant notre autre
assemblée posée par l'amendement de
notre collègue Dominique de leège qui
nous semblait satisfaisante et donc nous
avons regretté nous que l'Assemblée
nationale est encore choisi de s'écarter
des propositions du Sénat mais ce qui
est systématique maintenant en relevant
le seuil des strates de population de
20000 à 30000 habitants c'est encore une
fois ignorer le besoin de de
représentation des petites collectivités
parce qu'il y a des sentiments d'abandon
aussi qui
euh
augmente suite à à ce type de décision
et en particulier dans les départements
mélangeant des zones très urbaines et
des zones très rurales c'est pour cela
que nous souhaitons en revenir au texte
I et je ferai une explication de vote
plus plus
globale sur ce point merci monsieur le
Président ma l'avis de la commission
favorable madame merci l'avis du
Gouvernement
oui madame la Présidente nous avons bien
entendu les arguments qui ont été
développés nous nous avons dit hier très
longuement l'intérêt de cette conférence
territoriale de l'action publique qui
d'ailleurs avait montré toute sa
justification au cours des débats que
nous avons eu à plusieurs reprises
chacun a bien mesuré l'intérêt j'entends
bien votre observation monsieur le
sénateur et la nécessité d'entendre y
compris les collectivités de de plus
petite taille au départ notre objectif
était n'était pas tout à fait celui-là
néanmoins contenu des arguments que vous
avez développé de l'argument de de notre
rapporteur le gouvernement donne un avis
de sagesse merci madame la ministre je
vais mettre au voie à monsieur mzard je
vous en
prie B je madame la Présidente mais
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
non je ne retire pas laement je voulais
simplement attirer l'attention et je
remercie à la fois le rapporteur comme
d'habitude de son souci de trouver un
consensus et de faire avancer dans le
bon sens le texte et et votre avis de
sagesse madame la ministre mais je ve
dire à à mes collègues parce que je
souhaite que ce soit au au procès-verbal
que ce dont nous discutons depuis
plusieurs textes moi je l'ai trouvé de
manière intégrale dans un document de
février 2012 qui s'appelle l'avenir de
la décentralisation qui est un document
de Terranova dans lequel je trouve à la
fois l'élection des conseillers
départementaux au scrutin binominal
majoritaire à de
Tours j'y trouve à la page
19 un autre facteur de clarification de
l'action publique local qui serait la
contractualisation d'un partenariat
territorial entre plusieurs échelons de
collectivité territoriale au travers de
pacte de gouvernance territoriale pour
la durée du mandat celui-ci serait
élaboré et négocié par une conférence
des exécutifs locaux réunissant le
président du conseil régional les
Présidents de Conseils généraux et les
présidents des intercommunalités et et
vous avez ensuite
évidemment le but qui une finé sera
poursuivi cette contractualisation
interviendrait au plus tard 18 mois
suivant les éle tion générale et
définirait un cadre d'intervention ainsi
que les grands axes stratégiques de
l'action des collectivités sur le
territoire régional ceci a été élaboré
en 2011 et le document est de février
2012 et j'y trouve à la page suivante
parce que il y a pas de génération
spontané dans l'activité humaine j'y
trouve à la page suivante pour cela nous
proposons la création d'un Haut Conseil
des territoires structure permanente
créé par la loi et réunissant les
associations représentant les différents
échelons de collectivité locales le Haut
Conseil des territoires sera
obligatoirement consulté par le
gouvernement sur tout projet de réforme
ayant une incidence directe ou indirecte
sur l'exercice des compétences des
collectivités locales j'invite mes
collègues à la lecture attentive de ce
document dans lequel on retrouve tout ce
qui semblerait être élaboré ensuite par
le Parlement et par l'Assemblée
nationale mer merci monsieur le
Président ma monsieur le président suur
vous avez demandé la
parole merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues l'intervention de notre
collègue Jacques mzard m'amène à faire
une mise au point car ce
document d'un club de réflexion qui
existe librement dans la société de
liberté à laquelle nous sommes attachés
m'a littéralement poursuivi pendant
toute la campagne des élections
sénatoriales peut-être monsieur Larcher
s'en souvient-il j'allais dans telle ou
telle commune on me dis mais d'ailleurs
teranova dit
que et ben oui ben je disais ben écoutez
ils ont toute la ils ont toute la
capacité ils ont toute la capacité
monsieur Larcher à dire et à écrire ce
qu'il souhaite nous sommes dans une
société de liberté et il existe
d'excellents groupes de réflexion club
de réflexion il en existe à droite à
gauche et au centre et partout et ce
sont des des des groupes qui
réfléchissent qui publie quantité de
documents mais qui n'engage pas une
formation
politique mais non mais qui n'engage pas
une formation politique donc moi je je
lis toujours avec intérêt d'ailleurs je
n'ai pas le temps de lire toutes les
productions de ces de ces instances qui
qui travaillent beaucoup mais ça
n'engage strictement personne alors moi
j'été poursuivi par quelques élus de
l'opposition qui étaient là avec
Terranova
Terranova et mais monsieur mard pas les
élus de la majorité encore à ce jour
mais je vois que vous vous intéressez à
cette littérature et vous avez raison
d'ailleurs parce que cela stimule la
réflexion mais cela n'engage aucune
formation politique il faut le dire
puisque c'est la
vérité merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur
Colomba sa erreur de ma part conspirer
ça veut dire respirer
ensemble je le problème c'est que c'est
pas seulement le problème des clubs de
réflexion quand on trouve quand on
trouve les mêmes rédacteurs dans les
cabinets qui élaborent les propositions
de loi
confè le fameux binôme
confè le fameux binôme duquel on n pas
pu faire bouger le le ministre de
l'Intérieur et pour cause l'auteur du
projet il était là bon on se pose quand
même quelques petite question et
d'autant plus que j'ai la faiblesse de
penser que les propositions que nous
avons faites ici et d'ailleurs
maintenant on me le dit assez
régulièrement c'est-à-dire un mode de
scrutin qui pourrait s'appuyer plutôt
sur les intercommunalités paraît quelque
chose d' un peu de bon sens donc
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois je ne vous ferai pas l'injure
de vous croire
naïf c'est le c'est un des problèmes de
fond de notre système tout à hier quand
j'évoquais la Constitution de l'an 8
j'étais pas si loin de là c'est-à-dire
que l'initiative des lois la discussion
du loi et cetera est faite ailleurs
qu'ici et et pas vraiment au
gouvernement elle est faite dans les
cabinets elle est préparée avant et vous
pouvez suivre la ligne les lignes rouges
depuis 10 ans ou 15 ans et d'ailleurs
les majorités peuvent changer les mêmes
idées les mêmes idées restent c'est ça
le fond du problème de notre démocratie
du moins ce qu'il en reste et je crois
que Jacques mard a mis le doigt oui oui
bah peut-être mais en tout cas c'est un
des problèmes
essentiels chers collègues je vais donc
mettre au voix l'amendement 360 rectifié
présenté par notre collègue le président
mard j'ai a eu un avis favorable de la
commission en avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui est
pour merci
contre
abstention il est
adopté l'amendement 100 est présenté par
Monsieur yes merci madame la Présidente
puisque les conférences territoriales
vont réunir beaucoup de catégories de
collectivité il paraît indispensable que
les groupements de collectivité
territorial qui exercent des compétences
en matière d'environnement et dont le
périmètre d'action pertinent ne
correspond pas bien souvent à celui des
bassins de vie des EPCI à fiscalité
propre je pense que nous y reviendrons
longtemps souvent hein dans dans la
suite du débat il est indispensable
qu'elle soit représenté au sein de la
conférence territoriale surtout qu'il y
a souvent des des actions communes entre
les divers niveaux de collectivité
concernant je pense notamment tout ce
qui concerne les les syndicats de
rivière madame la ministre
vous avez eu un exemple
récent mer si Monsieur yes je vais
demander l'avis de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur l'observation du président
yes est naturellement pertinente elle
doit se concilier avec l'observation
qu'il faisait de manière tout aussi
pertinente hier en disant il faut garder
une configuration la plus souple
possible de la CTAP c'est pourquoi le
texte de la Commission prévoit que les
organismes non représentés peuvent être
associés aux travaux de la CTAP en
fonction de l'ordre du jour donc je
crois qu'il a
satisfaction même si on peut pas donner
de manière statutaire générale et
définitive un un un droit à une présence
permanente aux représentants des 10
syndicats voilà donc je demande dès lors
le retrait au président mais hier sinon
un avis défavorable merci monsieur teur
madame la ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement
oui madame la Présidente je je vais être
amené à à émettre le même avis et en
relisant justement la les dispositions
qui viennent d'être rappelées dire que
cette conférence peut-être peut associer
à ces travaux tous ceux qui a un titre
ou un autre ont à connaître des
problèmes qui sont évoqués donc les
syndicats et vous l'avez signalé ce
effectivement sur les problèmes de
bassin bassin versant sont effectivement
essentiel dans les dans l'étude et des
situations qui seront à examiner mais je
crois que notre texte aujourd'hui répond
déjà à l'attente tout comme elle va
répondre à l'amendement suivant
concernant la présence d'un membre des
parcs naturels régionaux merci madame la
ministre monsieur yes vous êtes
sollicité par deux fois pour un retrait
que décidez-vous
oui je vais pas compliquer les affaires
parce que ce bazar c'est pas la peine de
compliquer les choses je vais le
retirer chers collègues je suis saisie
de deux amendements identiques faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 36
rectifier bis monsieur verreto oui merci
madame la présidente madame le ministre
mes chers collègues cet amendement fait
éco à à celui qui vient d'être évoqué il
vise à améliorer la représentativité de
la conférence territoriale de l'action
publique sans pour autant rendre sa
composition plétorique ce qui nuurait à
son efficacité sur les territoires les
parcs naturels régionaux concours à
l'objectif de mise en œuvre concertée
des compétences des collectivités
territoriales en rassemblant les
communes autour d'une charte qui
détermine les orientation tant de la
protection de l'environnement que du
développement et de la mise en valeur du
territoire l'article r333 144 précise
que le syndicat mix d'aménagement et de
gestion du parc naturel régional dans le
cadre fixé par la Charte assure sur le
territoire du Parc la cohérence et la
coordination des actions de protection
de mise en valeur de suivi d'évaluation
de gestion d'animation et de
développement mené par les collectivités
territoriales et les établissements
publics de coopération intercommunale à
fiscalité propre ayant approuvé la
charte par l'État et par les partenaires
associés cont tenu de leur rôle de mise
en cohérence des politiques publiques et
des acteurs il nous paraît légitime que
les syndicats mix soient représenté au
sein de la conférence territoriale de
l'action publique j'ai bien entendu ce
qui vient d'être dit c'est dire je
voudrais exprimer l'inquiétude des parcs
naturels régionaux leur difficulté à à
trouver leur place dans dans les éfice
institutionnel qui se construit
notamment par rapport à à l'émergence
des pôles ruraux d'équilibre et de
solidarité territoriale dans les
départements donc ce cet amendement
serait une réponse à à leur
inquiétude chers collègues le 190 n'est
pas défendu il tombe mais il est
identique donc je vais demander à
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de la
commission la position est la même que
tout à l'heure hein les organismes non
représentés peuvent être associés aux
travaux des CTAP en fonction de l'ordre
du jour c'est évidemment le cas des
parcs
naturels merci Madame la Ministre même
avis même avis en en suggérant peut-être
un
retrait si merci Madame le Ministre
chers collègues vous êtes sollicité vous
le retirer
merci l'amendement
38 présenté par Monsieur Fillol au nom
de la commission de développement
durable vous avez la parole chers
collègues merci madame la Présidente
écoutez dans une cap une CTAP à
la commission du développement durable
pensait que les pôles ruraux pouvaient
avoir leur place mais étant donné le le
débat que nous avons eu hier je suppose
que madame la ministre vous allez me
demander de retirer cet amendement ce
que je ferit tout en rappelant que les
pôles ruraux devront à leur demande
évidemment participer au débat
lorsqu'ils seront concernés au sein de
la CTAP et je retire mon amendement
avant vous me le demandiez merci chers
collègues
l'amendement 361 rectifié présenté par
le président
mzard merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre il s'agit de bah de de
renforcer encore cette magnifique
conférence des
territoires en rajoutant les maires des
commune chef-lieu de département de la
région s'il ne figure pas par les parmi
les membres qui sont prévus parce que je
rappelle que
près d'une vingtaine de communes
cheflieu de département métropole
n'atteignent pas 30000 habitants alors
il y a le l'amendement à 20000 j'ai pas
fait le calcul exam il doit en rester
malgré l'abaissement du seuil et nous
considérons que toutes les commune
chef-lieu de département doivent être
représentés sachant que ma fois plus on
est nombreux plus la démocratie s'exerce
hein et je crois que c'est quand même
une bonne chose que que tout le monde
puisse faire entendre et qui est de de
grandes assemblée efficace et
compétente merci Monsieur mard l'avis de
la commission monsieur le
rapporteur la rédaction du texte de la
Commission prévoit que elle organise la
CTAP ses travaux dans le cadre de son
règlement intérieur je suis persuadé que
il est donc dès lors tout à fait
possible de trouver dans le règlement
intérieur une solution qui ne requiert
pas l'intervention de la
loi madame la
ministre je un avis de sagesse madame la
Présidente sur cette sur cet amendement
en reconnaissant effectivement la
nécessité d'une représentation global
mais je ne peux me rallier aussi qu'aux
observations du rapporteur merci c'est
une sagesse défavorable alors merci
Monsieur mard vous êtes qu'est-ce que
vous décidez je mets au voix je mets au
voix alors je mets au voix le 361
rectifié qui a un avis défavorable de la
commission et un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui est pour
alors merci qui est
contre il est adopté
merci l'amendement 489 rectifier bis est
présenté par Monsieur
biset merci Madame la la présidente
madame ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement reprend en fin de compte une
disposition adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale en première lecture et visant
à faciliter la mise en place des CTAP en
évitant lorsque là c'est possible le
recours à l'organisation d'élection des
élus non membres de droit ainsi il est
proposé que les associations
départementales de Mr représentativ
puissent assurer la coordination des
désignons des désignation des maires et
des Pres communautés non membres de
droit en respectant l'équili
démographique et géographique mais aussi
le isme politique lorsqu'une seule liste
complète est présente il n'y aurait pas
donc
d'élection merci chers collègu l'avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
cet amendement 489 donc l'alinéa 14 du
texte de la Commission prévoit un décret
en Conseil d'État pour préciser les
modalités d'élection et de désignation
des membres de la CTAP par par
conséquence pardon ce type de précision
qui a toute sa logique devra être prévu
dans le 10 décret donc peut-être que mon
collègue sous réserve de ce que dira le
représentant du gouvernement pourrait
accepter de retirer son son
amendement merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la
ministre le gouvernement est est
peut-être un peu plus favorable que ne
l' notre rapporteur sur cette
disposition et accepte la proposition
qui est faite par l'amendement
donc vous êtes favorable
merci je vais donc mettre au voix
l'amendement 489 rectifié bis présenté
par notre collègue Bizet avec une
demande de retrait de la commission
plutôt favorable et un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est
pour merci
contre merci abstention il est
adopté l'amendement 362
monsieur mard
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement a un sens par rapport au
débat que nous avons eu
hier nous avons en effet
proposé que dans cette conférence des
territoires soit rajouté par à l'alinéa
15 les mots désigne son président parmi
ses membres puisque nous voulons que la
démocratie s'exerce de manière tout à
fait transparente il est quand même
préférable que le président d'une
conférence aussi utile pour le dialogue
démocratique soit désigné par les
membres de cette conférence c'est le
moins que l'on peut attendre d'un
exercice démocratique et cet amendement
d'ailleurs revient à la logique de
souplesse qu'avait av voulu le Sénat en
première lecture car le Sénat avait
supprimé la présidence de droit du
président du conseil régional voilà donc
quel est l'objet de cette excellent
amendement merci monsieur le Président
mesard l'avis de la
commission moi je suis persuadé que si
l'on veut que la navette se développe
utilement il faut savoir comprendre
qu'il est pas illogique euh de prévoir
une présidence de la CAP par le
président de région qui anime impulse un
débat et qui n'incarne en rien euh un
principe de subordination hiérarchique
d'une collectivité sur une autre donc
même dans cette enceinte
le le représentant de la Commission amet
un avis
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis du Gouvernement madame la
ministre
oui merci Madame la présidente monsieur
sénateur j'entends j'ai bien entendu vos
arguments et le jeu démocratique que
vous appelez de vos vœux il n reste pas
moins que l'on est sur une conférence
régionale et pour des raisons toutes
bêtes de logistique d'organisation il
paraît utile de confier la présidence au
président du conseil régional et tant
entendu que il n'a pas il est seul par
rapport et au au présidents des
départements et aux autres membres de la
conférence territoriale donc il n'aura
pas une primauté
par rapport aux autres membres et je
crois que on peut donc tout à fait
utilement garder le dispositif qui est
proposé moi je vous demanderais si vous
acceptiez de retirer votre amendement
merci Madame la Ministre une demande de
parole de Monsieur sidau oui explication
de vote je l'ai dit hier soir il me
paraît normal que le président de cette
conférence fuselle régional soit désigné
de droit président effectivement il a
quand même c'est pas n'importe quoi il a
l'ordre du jour la maîtrise de l'ordre
du jour et par conséquent c'est il
devrait être élu parmi les siens euh je
dois dire d'ailleurs que je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec vous Madame la
Ministre est ne serait-ce que des pour
des raisons logistique mais au fond on
peut bien imaginer que cette conférence
territoriale est un lieu tournant de
siège tournant passe dans tous les
départements euh et par conséquent on ne
voit pas du tout pourquoi le président
du conseil régional serait de droit
président de cette conférence
territoriale je voterai donc
l'amendement de Monsieur
mzard Merci monsieur sidau monsieur
Favier
oui madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues nous voterons aussi cet
amendement parce que au sein de cette
conférence territoriale je crois que
toutes les collectivités représentées y
siégeront à égalité de droit et de
devoir donc il y a pas de raison
particulière même si on est une échelle
régionale que cette commission cette
conférence soit présidée par le
président de la de la région je crois
que tout autre élu effectivement
peut-être désigné par effectivement
cette conférence pourra exercer cette
responsabilité je partage effectivement
aussi l'argument pour dire que si très
certainement effectivement le siège du
Conseil régional peut-être le lieu
d'accueil de cette conférence ça n'est
pas forcément non plus une obligation ça
peut parfaitement effectivement tourner
sur les différents départements qui
compose effectivement ce territoire
régional merci Monsieur Favier la parole
est à monsieur le Président suur
merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je ne vais pas revenir sur ce
que j'ai dit hier
soir je pense que
la l'espèce de rivalité qui se
développerait
entre région et département pour moi n'a
pas de sens et dès lors qu'il s'agit
d'une conférence régionale
il me paraît vraiment
naturel
que le président de la région en soit le
Président il s'agit d'une instance qui
est une instance de dialogue un certain
nombre d'entre eux nous voulait la
supprimer nous nous sommes mis d'accord
sur une
version que notre rapporteur a
subtilement appelé
alléger c'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit d'un
lieu de dialogue euh qui permet
peut-être d'accorder un certain nombre
de choses euh de favoriser des
cohérences mais je pense que s'il y
avait ici au Sénat une crispation
antirégion ou contre les présidents de
région même s'il y a des dénégations
vous savez bien que ce serait perçu
ainsi et je je rejoins complètement ce
qu'a monsieurest ce qu'a excellemment
dit Monsieur richchart hier soir je
crois que ce serait une erreur c'est
pourquoi pour ma part je ne partage pas
cet amendement et je seraiis opposé à
cet amendement car il serait
nécessairement perçu négativement à
l'égard de région à un moment et à
l'égard de leur président où on a besoin
j'en suis convaincu de régions plus
fortes ayant avantage de moyens et de
prérogatives Madame le Ministre
oui madame la Présidente merci juste
pour rappeler et c'est peut-être le
pendant des observations qui avaient été
portées tout à l'heure et qu' avait et
qu'avait indiqué le le président mard
juste peut-être pour indiquer que la
délégation au collectivités
territoriales dans un rapport de 2009
préconisé de remplacer la Conférence
régionale des exécutifs par un conseil
régional des exécutifs ce que nous
faisons et indiquer que il fallait
assurer une périodicité trimestrielle
aux réunions de ce conseil des exécutifs
sous la présidence du président du
conseil régional nous nous en sommes
tout simplement
inspirés merci madame la ministre
monsieur mzard vous avez été sollicité
par par une demande de retrait voilà je
vous en
prie
la présidente madame la ministre mes
chers collègues j'ai bien écouté les les
explications des uns et des
autres alors madame la ministre a raison
de rappeler ce qui s'est passé à la
délégation mais il faut aussi rappeler
le contexte et puis le travail qui était
fait pour préparer le conseiller
territorial bon on va pas revenir
là-dessus nous ne sommes DUP ni les uns
ni les d'ailleurs je note que dans
l'excellent document
dont j'ai rappelé l'existence tout à
l'heure un sénateur important dans la
délégation des collectivités
territoriales a partagé cet excellent
travail de de Terranova mais fermons la
parenthèse mais sur le problème de deux
choses l'une où il s'agit d'une instance
de concertation que ce qu'on nous dit de
simple dialogue de rencontrre et bien
alors qu'est-ce que ça peut faire hein
que justement encore plus hein il y ait
un débat démocratique pour savoir celui
qui est le mieux à même d'apporter le
dialogue et le consensus vous sa je suis
dans une région je connais bien le
président de région je travaillé avec
lui pendant 25 ans je vous assure que si
je participer à cette conférence je
voterai pour lui sans aucun état d'âme
parce que on n'est pas toujours d'accord
mais je sais qu'il travaille et qu'il
travaille bien mais il faut laisser
s'exercer la démocratie vous pouvez pas
nous tenir constamment discours plus de
transparence plus de démocratie et puis
quand il s'agit de mettre en place euh
la présidence d'un organisme de dialogue
et de concertation dire ah ben non on
désigne là c'est quand même un discours
peu cohérent donc je maintiens mon
amendement
démocratique merci chers collègues
monsieur Savari
oui madame la Présidente euh vous
Rappelz qu'il y avait une conférence
régionale des
exécutifs euh nous le
découvrons puisque je n'ai jamais eu
l'occasion euh étant cumul d'être invité
à une conférence régionale des exécutifs
ce n'est pas pour autant que j'ai une
mauvaise relation avec mon président de
région je crois que les affaires sont
différentes selon les départements siège
du Conseil régional ou pas il y a une
véritable différence dans l'approche
dans le relationnel puisque il y a une
proximité quand vous êtes un département
où il y a le chefeu de région qui permet
de régler un certain nombre de problèmes
alors je crois que en instituant ce ce
ce pacte territorial il y a pas de
bouleversement ça marchera là où il y a
une véritable volonté politique de
travailler avec l'ensemble de ces des
partenaires ça ne marchera pas là où les
rivalités locales ou les postures
politiciennes l'emportent sur l'intérêt
général les choses sont clair donc
quitte à faire ce pacte territorial
soyons très souple et laissons la
possibilité à chaque territoire de
s'organiser le mieux possible je suis
sûr que même si ce n'est pas une
obligation que ce soit le président de
région qui dirige cette future
assemblée pour concilier les projets des
uns et des autres que naturellement si
le consensus se fait s'il y a la volonté
politique naturellement sera désigné le
président de région qui sera véritable
là pour coordonner les grandes
politiques alors cela se justifie parce
que mon approche moi territoriale c'est
de soutenir les département collectivité
de proximité et faire que dans
l'évolution des choses il y ait des
régions qui a des domaines de
compétences significatives dans le
domaine des grandes infrastructures dans
le domaine du transport ferroviaire de
l'économie de l'environnement de la
formation mais un échelon territorial
beaucoup plus conséquent que que l'on
connaît il y a une disparité d'échelle
entre les différentes régions moi je
fais partie comme nombreux quelques élus
ici d'e d'une région de petite taille la
Champagne Ardene il est bien sûr qu'elle
a pas la taille significative pour
pouvoir prétendre à faire des politiques
de développement du territoire net dans
le Grand Est de la France donc il faudra
réfléchir sur cette taille des région
insuffisante par endroit c'est pas du
tout la même problématique
effectivementenal peut bien entendu
paratre exemple hein donc je crois que
c'est ces difficultés territoriales qui
doivent s'exprimer à travers nos votes
de façon à prendre en compte les ces
disparités et je crois que la souplesse
fera que naturellement s'organisera
cette conférence territoriale donc j'ai
plutôt tendance à soutenir l'amendement
de Monsieur mzard Merci monsieur Savari
la parole est à Michel
Mercier merci madame la Présidente il y
a un point sur lequel je suis bien
d'accord avec monsieur Sueur c'est que
cette querelle Région Département est
exécrable et que ça n'a aucun sens aucun
sens en plus comme plus personne a le
moindre sous pour faire quoi que ce soit
tout le monde voudrait encore plus de
compétences et a moins d'argent pour
pour les réaliser tout ça tout
ça ne va pas moi je crois qu'il y a
qu'il faut regarder les choses avec
calme et sérénité c'est pas parce qu'on
met pas le président de la Région qu'on
va mettre un président de département
parce que si on regarde la
composition des conférences
territoriales telles qu'on vient de les
constituer qui est-ce qui sera
majoritaire ce sont les présidents
d'intercommunalité moi je vois
dans dans dans la région qui est la
mienne je pense que c'est celle qui
compte le plus grand nombre de
départements désormais il y aura neuf
départements euh on aura donc après
président de la Région ne présidents de
conseil généraux et on devrait avoir une
bonne trentaine même un peu plus de
présidents
d'intercommunalité
donc sera bien trop content d'être
président de ce truc c'est
évidenti je crois qu'il faudrait qu'on
prenne nous-même ici une position un peu
sereine et
d'escalier nous sommes arrivés à ce
qu'il y ait férence territoriale c'est
déjà un premier pas il faut pas
l'oublier c'était pas forcément gagné
d'avance il faut pas aller trop loin et
trop vite et puis il y aura une
CMP donc si on
sacralise le vote de l'amendement de
Monsieur bzard on va lui donner une
portée qui a probablement pas dans
l'esprit de son aur ni réellement quand
on regarde quand on regarde la
des conférences territoriales je suis à
peu près certain que aucun président de
conseil général ne sera élu président de
ces conférences
territorial
he non mais c'est bien pour ça c'est
bien pour ça composer en explication de
vote les régions et les départements
c'est pas la bonne explication je le dis
parce que j'ai entendu mais j'ai pas dit
que c'était ce qu' avait dit Monsieur
mard j'ai dit que c'était ce que j'avais
entendu et puis comme j'ai écouté tout
le monde en me taisant ce serait pas mal
que la réciproque soit également
vraie et oui c'est ça aussi
s voilà donc moi je pense que tout ça se
réglera en CMP et qu'il faudra bien
avoir des monnaes de dialogue en voilà
une très belle qui va être votée dans
quelques instants merci chers collègues
bien plus personne ne demande la parole
je vais donc mettre au voit à
l'amendement 362 rectifié j'ai été
saisie d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe socialiste sur
l'amendement de Monsieur mzard et
plusieurs de ses collègues je vous
rappelle que l'avis de la commission est
défavorable l'avis du Gouvernement est
défavorable il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin sera ouvert ver dans quelques
instants comment tu
vas le scrutin est
ouvert
personne ne demande à
voter le scrutin est donc clos j'invite
les secrétaires à procéder au
dépouillement
résultat du scrutin numéro 4 sur
l'amendement numéro 362 rectifié nombre
de votants 344 nombre de suffrage
exprimés 344 pour l'adoption 218 contre
126 le Sénat a
adopté nous arrivons l'amendement 363
rectifié qui est présenté par Monsieur
le Président
mard merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers
collègues dans notre souci de développer
la démocratie le dialogue et la
concertation et et je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui qui sera apprécié dans
nos
département nous proposons que les
réunions de ce de cette
conf se tiennent alternativement dans
chaque département de la région et je
vous assure que ce ça ça paraît
sibilin mais mais réellement je pense
que si ce type de conférence devait
prospérer et servir à quelque chose et
bien le fait qu'elle puisse se réunir
alternativement dans chaque département
sera apprécié par les élus locaux je
crois que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui va dans dans un accroissement de
notre souci de
démocratie merci chers collègues l'avis
de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur un commentaire avant si vous
voulez bien le conseil régional très
longtemps s'est réuni alternativement au
siège de chacun des des deux Conseils
Généraux donc je comprends bien la la
symbolique du que cherche le le
président
ma donc persuadé que je suis que même en
ayant enregistré le vote précédent
euh dans la pratique l'orme pour ne pas
dire la totalité
des des conférences territoriales seront
présidées par les présidents de région
anticipant donc malgré l'avis
défavorable que je suis quand même tenu
de rappeler de la commission des lois
dans le je pense que pour donner un un
gage à la recherche d'une coexistence
pacifique qui je le sais partagé par
l'immense majorité de mes collègues
représentants des conseil généraux à
titre personnel après avoir rappelé
l'avis défavorable de la commission j'
mettrai à titre personnel un avis
favorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre
oui merci madame la Présidente je je
crains que la disposition proposée
n'entre pas finalement dans un cadre
législatif rien ne s'oppose dans le
texte que nous avons aujourd'hui à ce
que la conférence puisse se tenir dans
l'un ou l'autre des départements donc la
liberté était était possible il y a des
règlements intérieur je crois que il
suffit que le règlement intérieur
propose que le chaque que à chaque
réunion de conférence on décide du lieu
où se tiendra la conférence j'attire
simplement moi l'attention c'est ce que
j'avais fait tout à l'heure pour pour
impulser l'idée que ça pouvait être le
président du conseil régional sur les
problèmes de logistique c'est tout mais
cela étant je crois que il est de de
bonne courtoisie de reconnaître que le
la la présidence enin que la la
Commission puisse se tenir
alternativement dans l'un des
départements
avis favorable madame la ministre en
tout cas de sagesse de sagesse merci la
parole est à Monsieur Sidou
oui pour explication de vote j'avais je
n'avais pas lu cet amendement avant de
prendre la parole à l'amendement
précédent j'avais évoqué cette
possibilité je suis donc tout à fait
tout à fait d'accord avec cet amendement
en soulignant qu' il est bon quand même
que les membres de cette conférence
territoriale connaissent la réalité de
chaque département parce que ou de de
chaque zone du territoire régional on ne
parle plus de département parce que dès
qu'on parle de département on a
l'impression qu'il a opposition entre
département région ce qui n'est pas du
tout le cas pour ce qui me concerne tout
au moins et donc je pense qu'il est bon
effectivement que les uns et les autres
puissent visiter des entreprises à
l'autre bout de la région visiter des
lycées ou des collèges à l'autre bout de
la région bref voir une autre réalité
qu'éternellement la réalité du du du
cheflieu centre de la région ou du
cheflieu centre de son
département les voyages forment les les
hommes la parole est à Monsieur Richard
oui madame la Présidente chers collègues
moi je suis dans une région composée de
deux départements alors vous avez
compris que l'alternance va pas être
très compliqué à mettre en œuvre mais
vous me permettrez de dire que au moment
où tout à l'heure on s'est réclamé de la
souplesse pour supprimer la présidence
de droit du du conseil régional bonjour
ici la souplesse enfin j'ai vraiment le
sentiment que dès lors que l'on donne la
liberté de désignation du président on
pourrait laisser aussi la liberté
d'organisation des travaux de cette
assemblée enfin quand
mêmeci Monsieur Richard monsieur
daliier merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
oui mon intervention va effectivement
dans le même sens autant j'ai voté de
bon cœur les amendements du président
mard autant celui-là franchement je je
je n'ai pas envie de le voter sinon on
peut rajouter un sous-amendement on
pourrait aussi décider dans la loi le
fait de savoir qui paye le pot de
l'amitié à la fin de la réunion
franchement est-ce qu'il faut
aller est-ce qu'il ou alors il y en a
plus effectivement parce qu'on a plus
les moyens on peu aussi non franchement
je crois que là nous allons trop loin
laissons cela au règlement intérieur
madame la ministre je pensais que vous
alliez conclure par un rejet de
l'amendement vous avez laissé la sagesse
mais honnêtement celui-là je ne peut pas
le voter en l'état merci Monsieur
daliier la parole est à Monsieur
Michel oui je trouve lAsie madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je trouve la proposition de
Jacques mard particulièrement
intéressante en
effet et je trouve même un peu
contradictoire avec l'amendement
précédent et oui parce que je considère
que laisser le au président du conseil
régional présidence de cette conférence
ça ne me paraît pas inopportun je trouve
ça logique par contre qu'on exige que
cette conférence tourne dans les
départements je trouve ça très
intéressant pour les
élus et pour les collaborateurs le
préfet de région le dral qui assistera
forcément à cette conférence on voit
parfois des préfets de région qui
passent 2 ans en région et qui ne
mettent jamais les pieds dans un
département on voit des Dréal qui ne
mettent jamais les pieds dans les
départements non mais ça ça m'est
arrivé alors au moins là
et forcément c'est en contradiction avec
l'amendement précédent parce que le
président de région qui ira dans un
département il demandera au président du
conseil général de coprésider avec lui
de fait la conférence avec le préfet à
ses côté donc je crois que c'est une
bonne disposition et je la voterai merci
Monsieur Michel la parole est à Edmond
Hervé
oui madame la présidente Madame le
Ministre mesdames et messieurs madame la
ministre je suis parfaitement d'accord
avec
vous la confusion est totale entre
ce que nous dit l'article 34 de la
Constitution et l'article 37 de cette
même constitution domaine législative
domaine réglementaire mais mes chers
collègues au point où nous en
sommes alors moi je voterai l'amendement
de de Monsieur
mzard parce que c'est un amendement
excellent même si sur le fond je
regrette qu'il faille un texte
législatif pour suér un président de
Région de faire le tour de sa région
merci Monsieur
HERV je vais donc mettre au voix
l'amendement 363 rectifié présenté par
notre collègue mard qui a eu un avis
défavorable de la commission mais un
avis favorable à titre personnel du
rapporteur et un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui est pour voter ces
amendement
11 qui est
contre
4 il n'est pas
adopté il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 502 rectifié
présenté par notre collègue madame
lipiz la parole
ch merci
euh nous venons de rejetter que un un
amendement au motif que il relevait sans
doute du règlement intérieur de la
conférence et cela m' paraît évident
chaque conférence doit pouvoir organiser
son propre règlement intérieur lorsque
ce règlement euh concerne uniquement les
relations au sein même de la conférence
comme le lieu où va se te dire cette
conférence euh la l'amendement que je
propose est un est le rapport entre la
conférence et les citoyens ce n'est pas
du tout du à mon avis du domaine du
règlement intérieur je propose que les
travaux de cette conférence soi publ il
ne faut pas qu'il y ait dans un une
région des travaux publics et d'autres
qui se font à H clos ça c'est bien le
rapport de la conférence avec les
citoyens donc je propose que tous les
travaux soient publics et que les
compte-rendus soient disponibles sur le
site internet des collectivités
concernées en format ouvert c'est-à-dire
réexploitable directement par les
citoyens merci madame lipiz je vais
demander l'avis de notre rapporteur sur
cet amendement avis dé favorable dans la
mesure où l'alinéa 17 du texte prévoit
déjà une publicité des travaux de la
CTAP selon les moyens matériels qu'elle
c'est-à-dire la CTAP juge les plus
appropriés merci monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis du Gouvernement madame la
ministre exactement le même madame la
Président je vous remercie monsieur
sidau oui pour pour explication de vote
madame la Présidente merci une fois
n'est pas coutume je trouve que cet
amendement est excellent et que nous
travaillons dans ces conférences
territoriales sous l'œil visé d'un
public intéressé et très présent mais
para une très bonne idée je voterai donc
cet amendement
personnellement je vais donc mettre au
voix l'amendement 502 rectifié qui a eu
deux avis défavorables qui est pour cet
amendement merci qui est
contre merci abstention il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 210 c'est un
amendement du Gouvernement je vous
invite à le présenter madame la ministre
oui madame la Présidente le gouvernement
propose
de simplifier c'était bien l'objet de
tout de tout ce texte et faire en
particulier que cette multiplication qui
nous a été reprochée de de schéma puisse
ici trouver le moyen d'être allégé et la
possibilité serait donc
donnée de de faire en sorte que
s'agissant des compétences partagées on
puisse rationaliser l'ensemble de ces
schémas pour les réunir en un document
unique en tout cas qui permettent de
libérer et le temps et l'énergie merci
Madame la Ministre l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
cet amendement du gouvernement s'il y a
une unanimité dans l'enceinte c'est sur
la nécessité de rationaliser les schémas
ça là-dessus jusque- là on vous
suit donc la question qui se pose
maintenant c'est comment on procède à
cette
rationalisation nous nous pensons à la
commission des finances que la
rationalisation des elle passe par une
loi si l'élaboration d'un schéma est
prévu par la loi il n'appartient quand
même pas aux collectivités de
rationaliser leur élaboration donc on on
a
euh selon moi des échéances à venir que
Madame la Ministre Lebranchu a rappelé
hier si j'ai bien compris elle a dit
début d'année pour le texte sur la
région et le département et bien
intégrons cette disposition dans cette
loi-là euh en terme de rationalisation
de schéma ça s'y prête d'autant plus que
ça nous permettra de définir exactement
la portée par exemple du strat ce qui
s'y trouve et ce qui s'y trouve pas mais
essayons de pas faire ça dans un
amendement futile gouvernemental
aujourd'hui donnons-nous un temps de
travail de concertation suffisant et
mettons-le en perspective encore une
fois je suis enthousiaste à l'idée de la
simplification des schémas vous l'avez
bien senti mais euh donnons-nous la
possibilité de le faire par la loi et
inscrivons ça dans la perspective du
texte à
venir merci monsieur le rapporteur donc
j'entends un avis défavorable n'est-ce
pas merci la parole est à
gaangorés je pense que cet amendement
est symptomatique malheureusement d'une
difficulté que nous avons à traiter dans
le cadre de ce débat et plus
généralement sur l'administration
territoriale de la France qui est que
nous avons là un texte intéressant utile
mais qui reste au milieu du gay et que
le débat n'a pas été poussé jusqu'à son
terme on cherche à rationaliser un
schéma parce que l'on aa pas tranché
clairement sur l'attribution des
compétences on cherche à mettre en place
une conférence territoriale dont on
débat de savoir qui est le mieux placé
pour la présider y compris donc autour
de la présidence de la région parce que
l'on n'a pas tranché qu'elle était
clairement le chef de fil sur un sombre
de dossiers le véritable problème auquel
nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui dans
nos territoires ruraux mais aussi
métropolitains c'est un problème de
développement c'estàdire de mobiliser de
réunir les énergies pour soutenir la
création d'entreprise la création
d'activités la création d'emplois les
projets de solidarité et c'est dans
cette logique que l'on aurait dû
envisager la réorganisation territoriale
on est je crois sur un schéma beaucoup
trop classique qui montre aujourd'hui
ses limites et qui oblige le
gouvernement à faire des exercices un
peu périlleux de réécriture pour amener
effectivement à préciser ce qui n'a pas
été initialement personnellement je
tiens à dire ici combien je regrette que
nous soyons saisi d'une réforme qui est
une réforme à minima et que les enjeux
de l'organisation territoriale auraient
mérité beaucoup plus que ce document
complexe qui ne tranche pas
véritablement entre les sujets
essentiels et qui ne s'inspire pas du
logique qui aurait dû être de mon point
de vue la logique du développement des
territoires merci Monsieur Gor la parole
est à Monsieur
Savari
madame la présidente madame j'ai
pratiquement rien à rajouter à ce que
dit Monsieur Gor c'est c'est l' viis que
je partage entièrement vous rendez
compte on est là à décider pour les
territoires s'ils doivent rationaliser
ou pas leur
schéma attendez c'est véritablement de
leur responsabilité de savoir comment il
va avancer et le but de cette conférence
c'est certes de partager des idées mais
peut-être effectivement de rationaliser
surtout le coût des services que l'on va
rendre quand même qu'on y mette les
moyens si encore l'état mettait les
moyens par par rapport à cette demande
de responsabilité responsabilisation des
des territoires on pour avancer mais là
ça va être quoi il y a il a il y aura
des
objectifs nous n'aura pas nous n'aurons
pas forcément les moyens de les réaliser
d'autre part les schémas sont bien
spécifiques et avancent différemment
selon leur nature donc si vous voulez
rationnaliser dans un schéma global on
va attendre que chaque schéma avance
donc je crois que c'est de la
responsabilité justement des élus locaux
de voir comment ils peuvent travailler
intelligemment
ensemble laisser les faire de la
souplesse dans le dispositif vous voyez
on a même pas tranché sur le
numérique dans certaines régions ce sont
les régions qui avance dans d'autres
territoires ce sont les départements qui
avancent bah c'est bien puisqueil y a
une collectivité qui prend les choses en
main mais après on laisse la libre
organisation pour un certain nombre de
domaines qui sont toujours transversaux
et qui ne peuvent avancer que s'il y a
une réelle volonté politique et les
moyens de réaliser derrière cette
volonté politique donc le débat est
aujourd'hui complètement je dirais
ahurissant
ahurissant par rapport aux enjeux
locaux merci Monsieur Samari la parole
est à Edmond
Hervé madame la président nous sommes
les uns et les autres victimes du
vocabulaire nous avons tous les uns et
les autres à tort ou à raison parler de
bloc de compétences j'ai toujours
contesté cette notion de bloc de
compéten qu'il y ait des attributions de
compétence oui mais aucun exercice de
compétence ne peut se faire sans le
partenariat la concertation et la
contractualisation et ceci vaut pour
l'État et les collègues qui au nom de la
simplification
entendent dire qu'il faut que l'État et
des attributions très précises se
trompe nous ne sommes pas dans un état
fédéral ça c'est l'élément fondamental
alors madame la ministre je vais pas me
répéter concernant l'observation de la
Constitution mais je voterai votre
amendement simplement je me dis quel est
le président de conseil général quel est
le président de département quel est le
maire ou le président d'une communauté
qui ne serait pas d'accord pour que ses
voisins formulent des propositions de
rationalisation écoutez tous les jours
nous faisons ce genre de choses et si on
ne les fait pas et bien nous ne sommes
pas dignes de l'intérêt
général merci chers collègues monsieur
le Président je si vous en êtes d'accord
je donne d'abord la parole à Monsieur
Favier monsieur Richard monsieur Favier
vous avez la parole
oui madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je je ne vois pas non plus
vraiment l'intérêt de de cet
amendement on a une conférence
territoriale qui va permettre le débat
entre des collectivités qui exercent
pleinement leur responsabilités pourquoi
faut-il là encore dans ce texte de loi
vouloir je direa encore corseter une
certaine manière leur
organisation beaucoup ici ont fait part
je dirais de dire du fait qu'il fallait
faire confiance à l'intelligence
territoriale faisons réellement
confiance à l'intelligence territoriale
effectivement quotidiennement
département région communes travaill
aujourd'hui à rationaliser à voir
comment on organise mieux un certain
nombre de compétences qui sont partagées
qui qui sont communes euh je ne vois pas
pourquoi il serait nécessaire là encore
de le préciser dans dans dans dans dans
ce texte il faut donc laisser
effectivement je crois dans le cadre de
ces conférences territoriales les
collectivités décidaient librement de la
manière dont elles entendent évidemment
travailler merci chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Richard
oui madame la
Présidente deux observations la première
c'est que je voudrais vraiment
rejoindre les interventions de gaetangor
et René Paul Savari
et et dire que je je suis quand même un
peu surpris de voir le gouvernement
proposer un amendement visant à
permettre à des
collectivités de rationaliser une
compétence
partagée rien que cela on dit long sur
allez la faiblesse et et ce terme je
l'utilise par charité chrétienne la la
la faiblesse de ce projet de loi en
matière de de de décentralisation alors
même qu'on nous
annonçait un un un texte faisant
référence et particulièrement couragé je
je je répète cet amendement à moins que
je ne l'ai pas bien compris vise à
permettre à différentes collectivités de
de rationaliser l'exercice d'une
compétence partagée c'est c'est c'est
bon voilà deuxème observation je n'en
vois vraiment pas l'intérêt madame la
ministre j'ai bien compris peu peu le le
l'amendement propose d'autoriser une
collectivité à à à rationaliser si elle
le souhaite si elle le souhaite peut
peut proposer il va de soi que comme
vient de le dire monsieur Fabier je vois
mal une collectivité ne pas aller dans
ce sens si elle voit une possibilité de
rationalisation de cet exercice de la
compétence donc outre qu'elle cet
amendement donne donne un signe fort de
quelque chose qui est en fait
euh la démonstration d'une faiblesse du
texte je n'en vois vraiment pas
l'utilité merci Monsieur réchard la
parole est à Monsieur
detreg merci madame la Présidente je
disais hier soir que ce texte crée de la
complexité ben voilà on peut pas
l'avouer mais on en est conscient donc
on essaie de rationaliser la
complexité franchement on est mal parti
on est mal parti il y a pas eu de vraie
réflexion d'ensemble avant de nous
proposer ce texte enfin je je le crains
ou pas suffisamment on va dire à mon
collègue Hervé là je le vois réagir on
va dire il y a pas eu suffisamment de de
de réflexion d'ensemble mais c'est vrai
aussi que on est là avec des des textes
comme ça on est dans le je dire dans le
fonctionnement quotidien faut aussi
faire un peu un peu confiance aux hommes
aux élus qui sont à la tête des diverses
collectivités élus mes femmes oui bien
entendu
euh mais c'est vrai n'entrons pas dans
dans des détails comme ça dans la
loi merci Monsieur desrag monsieur
sidau merci madame la Présidente oui je
crois que monsieur favlier a eu un mot
très intelligent tout à l'heure et très
important il a parlé de l'intelligence
territoriale enfin franchement
euh tous les jours on se téléphone tous
les jours on se voit tous les jours on
discute on prépare des contrats
actualisation on on rationalise tous les
jours comme Monsieur Jourdain fait de la
prose tous les jours est-ce qu'il y a
besoin d'un d'un texte de loi pour le
dire l'affirmer c'est une très bonne
chose en soit qu'on rationalise mais
est-ce besoin de l'affirmer dans la loi
alors que c'est pratiqué au quotidien
très honnêtement alors je serais pas
cruel mais cela traduit effectivement
cet amendement tout ce qu'on a décidé
plus haut et bon donc je comprends bien
mais en
attendant chacun doit croire que sur le
territoire et constater que sur les
territoires on ne fait pas que des
bêtises quand même merci chers collègues
madame
Lipietz merci madame la Présidente moi
j'avais l'impression tout simplement que
c'était déjà satisfait euh par au moins
deux autres paragraphes de l'article 4
la le paragraphe 3 puisque c'est la
définition même de la conférence
territoriale de débat et de rendre des
avis sur tous les sujets relatifs donc
le fait que l'exercice d'une compétence
euh pose des problèmes de
rationalisation me paraît relevé de cet
objet et de même à l'article 16 de ce
même article 4 où euh chaque membre peut
proposer l'insccription à l'ordre du
jour de questions complémentaires
relevant des compétences exercées par la
personne publique ou les catégories des
personnes publiques donc je pense que on
a déjà une le texte est déjà
suffisamment clair et c'est pas la peine
de rajouter des détails sur ce que peut
s'occuper la conférence des AFF
territoriales merci je donne la parole
au président
suer madame la Présidente euh madame la
ministre Anne-Marie Escoffier bon il
existe une commission des lois j'ai
l'honneur d'en exercer la présidence que
mes collègues ont bien voulu me confier
la loi est définie par l'article 34 de
la
Constitution c'est le 50e anniversaire
de la
Constitution
bien Madame la Ministre j'ai l'honneur
de vous demander de bien vouloir retirer
cet amendement du Gouvernement je vais
expliquer pourquoi je fais cette
demande nous avons eu beaucoup de débat
sur cette conférence territoriale un
certain nombre d'entre nous étai très 6
an considérant monsieur le rapporteur en
connaît considérant qu'il y avait une
région d'un département des communes des
communautés que chacun avait ses
compétences et que pour ce qui était des
compétences partagées chaque
collectivité avait la capacité de
dialoguer avec les
autres nous nous sommes finalement mis
d'accord sur une version
allégere qui fait de cette conférence un
lieu de dialogue bien il va de soi qu'au
cours de ces des réunions de cette
instance on peut
parler je pense qu'il n'est pas utile de
faire un article de de loi pour dire
qu'on peut
parler cet amendement ne dit que cela je
suis heureux madame la ministre que nous
puissions parler mais vous voyez bien
qu'on peut parler sans un amendement et
sans cet article regardez je le lis
lorsque l'exercice d'une compétence
autre que celle mentionnée à l'article L
111191 est partagé entre plusieurs
catégories de collectivité territoriale
chaque collectivité territoriale où est
établissement public de coopération
intercommunale fiscalité propre
attributaire de cette conférence peut
formuler des proposition de
rationalisation de son exercice donc je
suis dans une réunion voyez conseil
municipal conseil général et je peux
proposer que l'exercice de mes
compétences de nos attributions soi plus
rationnel mais aije besoin est-il utile
en quoi est-il utile d'écrire cela ça va
de soi heureusement encore heureux
imaginez imaginez que quelqu'un propose
de de voter le contraire on fera un
article pour dire que il n'est je vois
pas comment on pourrait être contre il
est interdit dans une conférence de de
rationaliser les
choses donc on est dans alors je sais
que le Conseil d'État a choisi de
publier son rapport annuel sur le
concept de droit
souple bien mais je crains qu'on arrive
là à quelque chose qui n'est pas du tout
du droit et qui n pas d'utilité donc bon
on a accepté qu'il y ait cette
conférence qui est un lieu
institutionnalisé mais qui n'a pas
d'autre objectif que de permettre aux
personnes de se rencontrer comme ça se
passe d'ors et déjà dans beaucoup de
régions n'en rajoutons pas et donc
vraiment je vous demande en vertu de la
Constitution dont c'est aujourd'hui
l'anniversaire madame la ministre de
retirer cet amendement merci monsieur le
président sû madame la ministre après ce
débat long euh monsieur le président de
la commission des lois vous demande le
retrait que
décidez-vous madame la Présidente j'ai
entendu avec la plus grande attention
les débats qui qui que nous avons que
nous avons eu ici je suis sensible aux
remarques des uns et des autres et
j'étais la première hier à bien
expliquer que cette conférence devait
être ce lieu privilégié de dialogue où
chacun essayer de s'écouter de
s'entendre et de trouver des voix de
solution sur sur nos problématiques de
compétences je vais aussi souligner
quand même et signaler que je laisse de
côté les compétences dit exclusive je
veux revenir à ces compétences qui sont
partagées en particulier bon nous avons
eu des exemples on l'a dit hier le
tourisme on a parlé du numérique et on
se rend bien compte qu'il y a des
positions
qui ne sont pas concordantes et qu'il y
a un un endroit privilégié pour en
parler et pour en débattre là ce qui est
normatif dans l'amendement proposé par
le gouvernement c'est seulement
seulement l'obligation qu'il y a d'en
parler en CTAP c'est-à-dire que sur ces
sur ces compétences qui sont partagées
et sur lesquel il n'y a pas de chef de
fil qui soit clairement défini et bien
il y a un lieu et lieu c'est la
conférence territoriale de l'action
publique où l'on vient débattre et où
l'on doit débattre regardez la phrase il
y a un peu dans la première dans la
première phrase alors que la deuxième
phrase est à est à l'indicatif et donc
on est bien dans une obligation de
consultation de la conférence là où on
est sur des compétences partagées qui ne
font pas qui ne font pas l'objet d'un
consensus et je voudrais reprendre quand
même les propos de monsieur le sénateur
Hervé adedmond en disant
Edmond Hervé pardonnez-moi en disant que
là où il y a une nécessité bien entendu
de de débat et bien rien ne s'oppose
quand même à ce qu'on l'écrive en tout
cas donc le gouvernement garde son
amendement merci Madame la Ministre donc
je vais le mettre au voix il a eu un
avis défavorable de la commission qui
est
pour merci qui est
contre merci chers collègu abstention
l'amendement n'est pas
adopté nous en venons au vote sur
l'article 4 qui est pour voter l'article
4 je mets au voix l'article 4 mes chers
collègues je mets au voix l'article 4
qui est pour voter l'article
4 voilà merci qui est
contre merci abstention l'article 4 est
adopté après l'article 4 un amendement
365 rectifié qui est présenté par le
président mard
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues avant que
monsieur le rapporteur nen appelle une
nouvelle fois à
l'élégance je vais retirer cet
amendement merci chers cè
à l'article 5 l'amendement 382 présenté
par Monsieur
Colomba je crains d'avoir peu de succès
mais je voudrais quand même revenir sur
cette sur cette non non non non sur
cette
question comme je l'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure il n'y aura plus avec le nouveau
mode de scrutin de lien entre la
représentation territoriale et puis la
politique départementale
entre notamment un des outils
fondamentaux de cette de l'action dans
les départements les intercommunalités
et la politique du département il y aura
maintenant la conférence
régionale le meilleur moyen finalement
de d'établir un lien
entre les acteurs de terrain du
développement de développement de
terrain et puis et puis cette instance
qui est l'instance départementale et
l'instance régionale resterait encore
c'est la proposition que je fais qui est
forcément amendable qu'il y ait
régulièrement donc des des conférence
départementale où les échanges puissent
avoir lieu et où tout le monde à travers
cette conférence pourra être informé des
travaux de ce qui pourra se passer à
l'assemblée départementale et de ce qui
pourra se passer à la conférence
régionale voilà cette cette proposition
n'a pas d'autre but et je je rappelle
que quelque chose qui ressemble à ce
type d'organisation existe déjà dans un
certain nombre de
départements merci Monsieur Colomba
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur cet
amendement autant j'étais d'accord avec
mon collègue mard pour dire qu'il est
très bon très sain que la
Commission puisse de déplacer et se
réunir dans chaque siège des conseils
généraux autant là je peux pas suivre ni
la commission des lois d'ailleurs la
proposition de Monsieur Colomba donc je
lui demande le retrait sinon un avis
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur
savariver ah pardon pardon monsieur
Savari je n'ai pas demandé l'avis du
Gouvernement excusez-moi le gouvernement
n'y'est pas favorable madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur Savari
oui madame la président madame la
ministre là aussi je je pense que c'est
à chaque territoire de s'organiser comme
comme il a été dit véritablement la
concertation est obligatoire surtout en
période de rarfaction de l'argent public
que voulez-vous on sait bien que si on a
une notion d'aménagement de du
territoire elle doit être partagée et
ensuite elle se fait à avec des
partenaires je crois que c'est
essentiel les départements collectivité
de proximité sont pas acharné à défendre
que leurs compétences d'autant plus que
elles sont parfois particulièrement
onéreuses où ils sont acharnés c'est de
jouer la solidarité des hommes à travers
l'action sociale et la solidarité des
territoires à travers l'aménagement du
territoire et là ne va pas sans l'autre
donc c'est naturellement que pour
proposer une politique
départementale et bien on réunit
l'ensemble des partenaires à chaque
département d'avancer à la vitesse qu'il
souhaite je crois qu'il faut laisser là
aussi la
souplesse
nécessaire si Monsieur savar monsieur
Dalier monsieur